I definitely have a fear of death same
as anybody else and I would very much
like to not die while climbing you know
I was this huge huge wall but all it
takes is one move that doesn't feel
right for you not to be able to do it
maybe in 2015 I started talking to Jimmy
and shy about making a feature film with
me I didn't want some film about me
living in my van and going climbing I
want it film okay so I was like that is
that deserves the big screen you know I
mean okay if is the most inspiring wall
in the world it should be seen on a on a
big big screen if it's ever gonna be
shot we also really wanted to push you
know the cinematography and how it was
covered and you know this is a once in a
lifetime maybe once in a many many
lifetime event so we had to have a team
that was literally almost all
professional climbers and great
cinematographers the mind-boggling part
for me always was then then you have a
subject that doesn't have a rope so
adding that psychological dimension and
the pressure that brought had brought
with it and just the weight that they
carried and there was heavy yeah close
friends and I think that Jimmy and I
were really looking to make a film about
Alex at a depth and that could explore
his character because the character is
fascinating it was interesting because
I'd sort of envisioned that is making a
climbing film which I have a lot of
experience with as a professional
climber and and that whole aspect of it
was sort of fine what wound up being
sort of challenging for me was the
Verity side all the the real-life
footage like my my home life and my
relationship with my girlfriend saw me
and just what it meant to have a camera
around me all the time when I wasn't on
the wall I mean the film unfolds over
two years and it's basically just a
two-year snapshot on my life and it's
pretty pretty honest and pretty pretty
bare you know like that's it that's it's
all it's all there
[Music]